any weather
Fried Chicken okay thanks for thanks for
the segue into this segment nice job
good job that was a that was a softball
for crying out loud
it's barbecue barbecue this is barbecue
time you got football barbecue and we've
got one of the best right here we've got
Chef Bruce from Soul Man barbecue how
are you doing here good to see you good
to have you with us you've got a big
event coming up on the 30th we do we do
a lot of events so it's a lot of fun you
know we have a great space for events
for you know corporate corporate events
and things like that but then we do our
own collabs you know I've got Chef
friends all over the country right and I
love bringing them in and you know we've
done we did a tiki bar pop-up and I did
a Huli Huli Pig I did a um an Asian uh
like a Ramen and Egg Roll pop up with my
buddy Lenny chin
um things like that and it's just it's
exciting that barbecue is like a blank
canvas when it comes to food right right
it can anything can be
um sort of collap mixed with barbecue so
on the the 30th you're teaming up with
John tasers yeah so I'm really excited
about this event
um not only because I get to see John uh
John and I've been friends for a long
time and we've done a lot of a lot we've
cooked a lot together yeah but uh
working with my buds at shinerbach and
Garrison Brothers who have very close
relationships with and you know they're
obviously they're Texas Brands and you
know they but they produce some
incredible products yeah and it pairs
well with barbecue we're actually the
biggest Shiner account in the state of
Nevada all right which is kind of cool
so they love us yeah I bet they do and
people love your barbecue as well you
brought just a sample here along with
some pork
well you know I just want for this for
today I just wanted to bring some some
foods that I think pair well with this
and you know this this dinner though is
gonna be like bougie barbecue okay so
that's what John and I do and then my
chef Marissa is actually a pastry chef
so she's gonna do the dessert course so
you have tickets that people can buy to
attend this event it's downtown yeah
it's January 30th on Monday it's only 85
bucks includes all of it drinks too yeah
yep and everything's gonna be paired
we're gonna have paired drinks and then
um yeah it's Monday January 30th all
right so the tickets just went on sale
so they are still available now yeah
probably gonna sell out you know yeah
it's on our the links right up on our
website okay should you come in there's
a pop-up window that pops up you can and
the websites there those who don't know
oh yeah soulbellybarbecue.com okay is
that BBQ BBQ yes so
um I just have some like pimento dip in
in our barbecue spice teach your own so
we make at the restaurant and you had a
funny name I know Rocky loves these yeah
pork rinds pork rinds and you call them
what get your own yeah I like that and I
think you know any obviously this is
great beer food right most barbecue is
you know but then we have our our
Carolina pulled pork sandwich and we do
a nice Carolina red sauce it's not like
the thick you know sweet sauce that you
see a lot uh and so it's light it's but
it's a little spicy pairs really well
with uh in this case we have our bacon
bourbon old fashioned with Garrison and
then this honeydew is probably one of my
favorite Bourbons it's a very light has
a little sweetness at the end it's
really good and it's great with spicy
food good stuff all right Chef Bruce uh
once again people can get tickets for
the event on the 30th Soul Man BBQ